eigentlich bekommen die Wähler oder
Deutschland gerade das nicht nur was sie
dieses Mal gewählt haben sondern genau
genommen was sie über Legislaturen
gewählt haben denn wenn man sagt grüne
Politik ist überall dann kann man
tatsächlich feststellen dass alle
Parteien auch allen voran die CDU ihre
Partei Herr bloss über Jahre
Legislaturen die Politik gemacht haben
die die Grünen jetzt auch faktisch
wieder an die Macht gebracht hat der
Ausstieg aus der Kernkraft die
Verdammung der Kohle Energie vieles
andere mehr das Märchen von der Energie
Verknappung als neuer Religion ist
nichts kurzfristiges sondern über
Jahrzehnte angelegt gewesen und ein
bisschen auch die deutsche
Gutgläubigkeit und vielleicht sogar die
gut gemeinte Absicht alles richtig zu
machen und vor allen Dingen alles
richtiger als alle anderen Nationen und
genau daran drohen wir jetzt zu
scheitern nicht nur im eigenen Land
sondern mit den europäischen Verbund
reißen wir auch die Nachbarstaaten in
Europa mit ins energetische Unglück und
treffen wird es wie immer die
Mittelschicht und die Ärmsten der
Gesellschaft all diejenigen die heute
eher auch selbst erwirtschaften können
und möglicherweise in die nächsten
Jahren von staatlichen Transfers
abhängig sein werden denn ein 300 Euro
Zuschuss wird nicht reichen wenn die
Energierechnung die Gasrechnung die
Stromrechnung pro Monat um mehrere
hundert Euro steigt und deswegen ist das
eigentlich ein Desaster und ich kann nur
hoffen dass viele der Bürger die aus
gutem Willen grüne gewählt haben jetzt
merken dass diese Art von Politik in die
absolute Mangelwirtschaft führt und dazu
kann ich nur sagen als gelernter die der
erbürger Mangelwirtschaft kennen von den
rund 80 Millionen Deutschen bisher
maximal 16 Millionen auch vielleicht die
jungen Leute gar nicht mehr ich finde
nicht dass es ein Ziel sein sollte das
weitere 60 oder 56 Millionen diese Art
von Mangelwirtschaft kennenlernen sie
trifft auch da fragen wir da einmal Frau
Hermenau sie als ex-grüner ist der
Vorwurf zu hart oder angebracht dass wir
mit den Grünen die Mangelwirtschaft
kennenlernen werden wir werden die
wangenwirtschaft kennenlernen und das
hat auch was mit der Ansage zu tun dass
wir uns bescheidener verhalten sollen
das wurde ja ein narrativ gekleidet das
finde ich sehr defensiv wir sind
eigentlich eine Industrienation und
nicht so ein kleiner Farmer Stream ne
sondern wir wollen eigentlich vorne
mitspielen das tun wir übrigens auch
wenn man sich die Zahlen vor Corona mal
anguckt gab es nur drei Länder auf der
Welt die insgesamt überhaupt in der Lage
waren für mehr als 1.000 Milliarden
US-Dollar
Dienstleistungen und Güter zu
exportieren China die USA und
Deutschland also England und Frankreich
müssen schon zusammenlegen im Export um
auf deutsche Größen zu kommen und das
riskieren wir gerade ganz massiv ich
verstehe nicht wie man
umverteilungsträume haben kann egal ob
in die soziale Schiene oder in die
ökologische Schiene wenn man kein Geld
erwirtschaftet ist unklar
Herr Ploss da kann man jetzt mal fragen
es ist ja jetzt nicht so als hätten nur
SPD und FDP mit den Grünen sympathisiert
in der Union haben ja auch einige mit
Schwarz-Grün vor der Wahl geliebäugelt
wer das denn jetzt noch eine Option für
Sie also ich wäre erst mal kurz zu dem
was sagen was Frau Petry immer erwähnt
hat ne und was bei ihm ja auch
durchschimmerte die Union ist schuld und
ein bisschen
die Frage zu beantworten jetzt kommt
erstmal
nein will gar nicht ein großes
Werbeblock einführen ich will auch sagen
natürlich hätte man mit dem Wissen von
heute früher auch einiges anders machen
müssen und natürlich sind auch
Entscheidungen die vor einigen Jahren
getroffen wurden aus heutiger Sicht
falsch man muss nur auch sagen im
Nachhinein ist man immer klüger und
spätestens nach dem 24 Februar dem
Angriffskrieg von Russland auf die
Ukraine hätte man Umsteuern müssen und
sagen müssen die Energiepolitik
Deutschlands die kann nicht mehr auf Gas
basieren und es müssen Alternativen her
neben den erneuerbaren und da glaube ich
nicht das Kernkraft eine wichtige Rolle
spielen wird aber bloß vielleicht darf
ich da kurz dazwischen gehen denn
tatsächlich ich verstehe dass sie als
CDU Politiker ihre Partei verteidigen
aber das ist so wie 2015 bei der
flüchtlingskrise zu sagen das war
Naturereignis wir konnten das vorher
nicht wissen und das was jetzt gerade
mit der Energiepolitik passiert ist ein
ist ein Scheitern Verzeihung mit Ansage
wir wissen seit langer Zeit dass uns die
erneuerbaren Energien keine Grundlast
bringen dass wir am Ende uns von Putin
abhängig machen konnte man sehen wenn
man die Menge russischen Gases mal sich
an sah die wir von dort exportieren und
nein
so wahrgenommen dass sie sich immer von
Russland abkoppeln wollte und das mal
etwas ich rede mit Energiepolitik der
letzten Legislatur und da müssen wir
feststellen dass Merkel ja auch gegen
den Willen der Parteien Fragezeichen
nur um da die FDP nicht rauszulassen es
waren FDP Politiker der Mitte der 90er
Jahre den
auf nach 5 D-Mark polite Benzin in die
Welt gesetzt hat es wird über den grünen
zugeschrieben die waren tatsächlich
damit beteiligt und haben es beschlossen
aber es waren FDP-Politiker und zwar der
Chef des Umweltbundesamtes der 21 Jahre
diese Behörde geleitet hat der hat diese
Forderung in Gang und zwar warum um die
Autofahrer dazu zu bewegen das Auto
stehen zu lassen und das ist glaube ich
was das größte deutsche Problem wir
versuchen ständig als Politiker die
Bürger zu erziehen aber das ist gar
nicht unsere bitte jetzt muss ich einmal
hart widersprechen weil weil sie sie
haben
früher ja auch Verantwortung getragen
auch in der AFD und die AFD war immer
die Partei in Deutschland bis heute die
eine ganz ganz enge Beziehung zu
Russland gesucht aber
wir bleiben bis heute verhandelt und die
bis heute sagt es sollen bitte
gasbeziehung mit Putin Russland geben
also gerade die hat ja nicht rausgelernt
und ja aber man muss aber sie haben
damals ja auch nicht gesagt also die
energiebeziehung in Russland abgebrochen
werden
wir bleiben einmal bei der
Energiepolitik und da würde ich dich
gerne Fragen Klaus ist kam mir jetzt
gerade so rüber als wäre erst durch den
Angriffskrieg der Ukraine klar geworden
das was falsch von diesem Land läuft
energiepolitisch ist es dir da auch erst
klar geworden also ich wäre mir das
jetzt angehört und so und wenn nicht
alles so traurig werden wenn wir nicht
wirklich voll in der Tinte sitzen würden
und wenn nicht Leute von pleite und
soziale Armut bedroht werden dann müsste
man eigentlich schmunzeln über alles
weil wir werden ja Zeuge eines
großangelegten sozialexperiments ich
glaube viele Wähler der Grünen wollten
gar nicht die Grünen wählen sondern die
wollten nur dass ich mal was ändert dass
man dieses großkoalitionäre Zeug zu Ende
ist und eigentlich fanden sie die Ideen
mit dem Lastenfahrrad und so auch ganz
niedlich und dann hat man gedacht jetzt
probieren wir es mal so rum das finde
ich erstmal okay klar muss jedem
verständigen Menschen gewesen sein dass
das der Einstieg in den Umbau einer
Gesellschaft ist denn wir haben ja jetzt
eine linke Regierung die ist nicht ganz
doll links aber sie ist links und sie
hat einen kleinen gelben Wicht kann auf
der Kasse sitzen mit dem Christian
Lindner als Finanzminister der sich
jeden Tag überlegen muss ob er den
Scheiß mitmacht und dann weiter an der
Macht bleibt oder irgendwann mal sagt
ich mache nicht mehr mit und alles in
die luftjagd da besteht da halt morgens
auf schaut sich den Spiegel und sagt gar
nicht so schlecht Minister zu sein und
dann macht das wieder mit ja und das ist
die Situation die ist aber nicht vom
Himmel gefallen um auf deine Frage zu
kommen sondern das konnte jedes haben
wir in diesem Studio haben wir das
beschrieben wir haben es diskutiert und
geschrieben dann sind wir angegriffen
worden als
zukunftsverweigerer als Retro Typen als
sonst irgendwas und jetzt ist es halt so
gekommen jetzt muss man sagen Ben luck
pech für die Grünen und die SPD das
jetzt so viele Krisen auf einmal kommen
bei denen sie in jeder einzelnen
versagen weil sie den falschen
politischen Kompass als Grundlage haben
nämlich ein sie haben es angedeutet der
Staat muss alles richten und man muss
die Menschen umziehen wir reden ja jetzt
noch gar nicht darüber dass da auch
eingepreist ist wie man sich benehmen
soll was man sagen soll dass man
Duschen soll jetzt der neueste Knüller
man soll also nur noch auf Sound zu viel
Quadratmetern wohnen und wenn man Kinder
hat dann kann man eine größere Wohnung
nehmen oder oder bauen aber dann soll
man gleich sozusagen zwei Türen einbauen
damit du dann die Kinder aus dem Haus
sind bloß nicht so viel Wohnraum hat die
die Baumeisterin hat solche lustigen
Träume aber das ist alles nicht von
heute auf morgen geboren wann das stand
immer überall und es war klar wenn es
rot grün wird mit ein bisschen Geld ähm
oder gar nur rot grün dann kommt das
alles und ich glaube auch dass man da so
schnell nicht mehr rauskommt insofern
sind diejenigen die das mal so als
Versuch in ihren Prenzlauer Berg und
München Grünwald Wohnungen mal so mit
überlegt haben das könnte man doch mal
so machen und so denn die sind jetzt
mit Täter eines Umbaus einer eines
großen gesellschaftlichen umbaust und
die CDU und ist auch noch zu sagen hat
sich natürlich in den Jahren zuvor in
den großen Fragen um die es geht auch
nicht mit Rum bekleckern
Migrationspolitik sprechen wir später
drüber Energiepolitik das haben wir
schon
natürlich alles richtig gelaufen ist
für die nächsten Wochen und Monate die
Leute haben einen scheiß Angst
macht Bling Bling Bling Bling Bling so
kommen die Menschen ja wir wissen die
Kuchen einladen ich habe gesehen drei
Stück Kuchen noch einen anderen dazu
drei Stück gucken 7,50 ich habe es
gelassen ich sage es in Ordnung komm her
kriegsen Kaffee so ist die Lage also die
Leute haben eine furchtbare Angst dass
sie in ein paar Wochen schon nicht mehr
in der Lage sein werden ihren normalen
Alltag zu finanzieren den sie gewohnt
sind wir reden darüber dass ich Strom
und Gaspreise das wird sich noch eine
Weile hinziehen das ist ein
streckbetrieb zur Sache in der
Preisentwicklung aber da kommt dass die
steigen zwei Drittel der Inflation die
in die jetzt vor der Haustür stehen und
zweistellig werden wird sind über die
Energiepreise ein Drittel sind andere
Geschichten denke ich so ungefähr eine
Größenordnung das Problem ist wir haben
also vor dieser Energiekrise in der
übrigens nur europa steckt kein anderer
Kontinent nur Europa hat dieses Problem
das hat auch viel mit dem mit der Vorhut
wir sind die Besten wir zeigen dass die
Deutschen wiederum in Europa noch ganz
besonders viel von diesen Problemen
abbekommen
diese Probleme nicht wir haben das
Problem das treibt die Preise nach oben
wir sind die armen Schweine die teuer
bezahlen müssen für das was sie wollen
wir haben aus der Pipeline das Gas zur
Hälfte billiger sage ich mal ungefähr
als das LMG dass dann irgendwann mal aus
Amerika mit Schweröl betriebenen großen
Tanger rüber geschippert wird ökologisch
angesagt dazu kommen wir später
wir haben früher für sag ich mal eine
Megawattstunde Strom haben wir
vielleicht so um die 50 bis 60 € bezahlt
wir sind jetzt in einer Preisrange von
200 bis 300 Euro sag mal 250 € pro
Megawattstunde und das bleibt die
nächsten Jahre so weil wir keine
Infrastruktur haben um irgendwas zu
ändern wir müssen eigentlich mit jedem
dämlichen Dynamo den wir irgendwo haben
jedes Kraftwerk alles was wir haben
selber Strom produzieren hier in
Deutschland selbst produzieren und
Zustande Peter damit wir der Lage sind
die Preise zu senken diese verfümfachung
der Preise können weder Mittelstand noch
die Bürger ertragen es wird nicht